the topic of sets is by far the simplest
topic to grasp in mathematics since we
have to tackle just three simple
questions first what are sets
second why do we need them and last how
do we represent them let's tackle the
first question in this video what are
sets a set is basically a collection of
things think about it what if you were
asked to make a list of all the things
you can see of course you can't write
all the things but some of the things
you would mention are a tree or cell
phone a puppy people and so on and what
if you were asked to write down a list
of things you cannot see you would
probably write oxygen heat and so on
these are the things you cannot see a
set is a collection of elements yes but
they have to be related in some way let
us look at a few more examples to
understand better try to list down all
the cricket playing nations you know of
I would probably have said India England
Australia Pakistan and so on now try to
list all the oceans you have heard of if
you didn't know there are five oceans in
the world Pacific Atlantic Indian Arctic
and Southern Ocean now here's an
interesting question can we make a set
of elements for all the questions you're
asked for the answer is no not
necessarily what if we were asked to
make a list of the good teachers we know
we cannot make a set here because my
idea of a good tutor may be completely
different from yours similarly we cannot
make a list of intelligent students we
know the word intelligent is not
well-defined so remember another
important characteristic of sets is that
the elements in it should be
well-defined
all the elements in a set should be
related and well-defined